- Let's this rad mom Christmas
with a truly shiny gem from
social media, this is what I'm liking.
(crowd cheering)
(crowd clapping)
I'm sure many of you helped santa with the
Elf on the Shelf ritual over
the years, it can be work,
(laughter)
but its worth it when you
do see your kids mesmerized
by the magic of Christmas.
One Texas mom has us all beat
she's trying to win some
award y'all this is awesome,
she helped ol' saint nick design
the ultimate glam situation
for her elf and his
friends, that line now what?
She's got a Met Gala theme
with Buddy the Elf hanging out
with three friends just
dripping with diamonds.
Yep casual Tuesday, and we've
got this super creative mom
on the line right now,
everybody say hello to
Ashley watching on NBC
5 Dallas Fort Worth,
What's up Ashley?
(crowd cheers)
- Hey girl hey, hi Kelly
- Hey girl hey, this is such
a cool idea, and I love that
that kind of magic like in
the the household, especially
with kids any age. Even adults its fine,so
take us through this years display though
- Well this is the Elf Met
Gala, and the theme this year is
Chroma Futuristica, and I was
just sitting in my living room
on a Saturday night, and
I looked over at one of my
Christmas gifts that I had
wrapped and it had Chrome
wrapping paper, and I
thought "maybe I should make
Buddy a suit, for when he
here in the morning and he can
put it on and maybe his friends
can join him, and I'll just
make them some outfits as well",
and my son woke up next
morning and was like
"Oh my gosh, what did the elves do?
They, they really went
extra this year" and I said
"They sure did, I don't expect anything
less from these elves"
- (laughing) This is so
creative and so cool Ashley
I'm liking your post right now
(ding from bell)
(crowd cheers)
- Thank you, Thank you so much
- Absolutely that's not
all girl, our season-long
partner Pilot Pen ,makers
of Frixion erasable pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly and
just awesome, just like you,
so they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars
how's that sound?
(crowd cheering)
- Oh my gosh, thank you so much,Oh my gosh
- That's a lot of creative
elf Met Gala's, I love it
thank you so much Ashley
and a big thank you to
all our guests this
hour, former first lady
Michelle Obama, Lawrence
,Megan Trainor and Matt Isaacs
Y'all have a great day now,
if it's not try and change it.